Joe Biden's got another Brewing
International crisis on his hands
growing fears of escalation between the
U.S and Russia after Putin down one of
our drones a Russian fighter jet
brazenly harassed the craft for over 30
minutes dumping fuel on it and then
crashing it into its propeller the
United States military then forced to
ditch it into the Black Sea Moscow
accusing America of an act of
provocation warning Biden to stop what
it calls hostile military action near
its borders seems like a pretty big deal
between two nuclear Powers right but not
so fast Joe Biden hasn't said a word
about it today and it looks like his
team wants to give the Russians a pass
the message that we delivered to the
Russian Ambassador is that they need to
be more careful and flying in
international airspace near U.S assets
that are again flying in completely
legal ways conducting submissions in
support of our national security
interests I think the best assessment
right now is that it probably was
unintentional it probably was the result
a profound incompetence on the part of
one of these Russian Pilots
Republicans say the incident's yet
another instance of Joe Biden acting
weak on the world stage
pissed off I mean let's just be honest
about this for a second the report
coming out of our government is that
this was an unprofessional act and
environmentally unsound if they shot
down a United States war plane they took
it out of action and that's the response
we get back this is yet another
dangerous provocation by Russia brought
about by years of President Biden's
weakness President Biden you're the
Rodney Dangerfield of world leaders
nobody respects you and if you don't
change your game and up your game we're
going to have World War III the Pentagon
also trying to calm things down and
promise the Russians got nothing of
value
as far as an active War goes I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna go there incidents
happen
um and and clearly uh we do not uh seek
armed conflict with uh with Russia it
probably broke up uh they're probably
not a lot to recover frankly as far as
uh the loss of anything of sensitive uh
intelligence Etc uh as normal we would
take uh and we did take mitigating
measures so we are quite confident that
whatever uh whatever laws of value is no
longer a value and so Dana what do you
think the right course of action should
be in a situation like this I think that
the cooler heads are prevailing at the
White House and at the Pentagon and that
that answer is really good you don't
know what's happening behind the scenes
and maybe there's more to that story I
think a couple of things one is I do
think it was right to ask for the
declassification of the video so that
it's very clear to the world who the
aggressor was here because Putin is
trying to say that it was the United
States well let's show the video Let's
show exactly what happened and also when
they said there was nothing done well it
was 32 million dollars worth of
equipment I mean that's no that's a lot
lot for uh people I know it's not in the
big scheme of the Pentagon budget but
it's still a lot so I would push back
hard on that because I don't think it's
right to allow Russia to dictate new
rules of engagement in international
waters because that's not good for us
it's not good for us when it comes to
China or any other International
conflict so I think that part is good
the other thing I think is that Putin
wants this to look like it's escalating
but not actually have it escalate so the
reason would be because he's got a
situation that where he's having a hard
time beating a ragtag military in
Ukraine and on the other side you have
Ukraine
that would like us to do more but we
can't allow them to stir the pot and
drag us into something as a third party
so I actually think that right now given
what we know that the White House and
the Pentagon cooler heads prevailing
being smart but one thing I loved when
President Trump was in office was nobody
knew exactly what he would do
right in this case it's like we're
pretty sure everybody knows what's going
to happen here which is nothing
um but they weren't sure when President
Trump was in office because you can
imagine even the back channel would be
don't you ever do it again right or we
could be doing things behind the scenes
cyber or Espionage which we might not
even know about well that stuff is going
on all the time but you know what's
interesting about this is that you know
they're trying to establish themselves
as a people the Russians as they have
control over the Black Sea I mean we've
already established it's international
waters we've been operating there for
what 15 20 years no one owns it that's
number one number two uh many of our
drones and I spoke to several people
from the military today have Sidewinders
our Rules of Engagement prevented us uh
from using a Sidewinder because we were
never in danger our drone was unmanned
all right so this is the Russians trying
to look tough at the end of the day what
our drones are doing there is we are
providing significant intelligence to
ukrainians about where the Russian
troops are so we may not want to admit
it but we're already in the middle of a
war and right now with respect to the
ukrainians uh if if they get the what is
it the M1A1 Abrams Tanks if they get the
new leopard tanks that are now in Poland
and The Chieftains tanks from the Brits
and they show up on the battlefield all
these countries have promised it game
over and so I heard General Keane today
he said something I thought was good he
said you know what
fly drones over that area again and
again and again don't let them think
that they have the power over us because
they absolutely don't
give us the Communist perspective oh my
gosh
I have to check my email first because
the talking points came in late today so
I'll just go with what I want to say
um which is
that I agree wholeheartedly with Dana on
the point about the cooler heads
prevailing right now and would just add
to that that when you hear Senator
rounds talking about this is because
Biden is so weak Lindsey Graham has been
going scorched to Earth about this the
reason that this is happening is
actually because Biden and the U.S and
the allies of Ukraine have been so
strong
because they're defending Ukraine at
this level and they're supplying with
them with that level of Aid and the
weapons that they need and so Russia is
angry at us and needs to do something
they need to do something that's not
going to start a war right that's just
going to keep pissing us off and I
hadn't heard General Keane but that
sounds right to me just keep going back
and back and back and it gets back to
2014 with the annexation of Crimea where
they're going around again saying well
it's their territory
it's not and when we see what happens at
the end of this war well excuse me we'll
have a very different picture of it but
to the point about it I've heard it
elsewhere about you know what would be
happening if it were president Trump
doing this President Trump and listening
to uh Governor DeSantis talking about
what he would be doing in terms of
Ukraine would not be standing with
Ukrainian people in the way that Joe
Biden is and the leaders of the the
Western Alliance and it would be a very
different picture but not in the good
direction so Vladimir Putin wouldn't
have to be going after our drones
because we would have I guess for
zelenski to seed more territory that was
his uh in the beginning he said just
give them a few things no big deal give
them the Don bass Etc
I think I think Trump's argument would
have been that this would never have
happened on his watch
let's get Greg in here you were saying
in the Green Room Make Love Not War I
say that all the time including in the
bedroom Jesse you know uh uh 32 million
for a drone Anderson Cooper must be
calling you agent
I just want to uh clearly Joe Biden is
in the pocket of Putin right or else he
would have reacted more strongly I'm
just using the left wing talking point
um because I didn't give it to you yeah
well no actually DeSantis thing is
interesting because he was saying
earlier that this was a territorial
dispute yeah which he's not wrong and we
pointed that out we pointed that out
when it started however it doesn't
matter anymore because if you walk away
from this uh War the ukrainians will be
crushed right but if you stay with it
two years four years ten years you got
Afghanistan maybe people cling into
planes it's a no-win situation for us
unfortunately and that's where we are so
I think that DeSantis can say that but
once he gets into Power he's probably
and if this happened under Trump he
would you would end up either having to
make this really really Stark decision
and right now this is not a big deal
this is silly why is I don't understand
ramping up this thing we're in a proxy
war right now we Supply arms and Intel I
don't care if it's a close pass if they
sprayed fuel if they harassed the plane
you know call HR for God's sake there's
nobody on it they had to press they had
a press conference for a damaged
propeller we've been pretty lucky that
all that's happened in this war to us
are the fighting of other people you
know what do you you don't want an
escalation out of this you already got
billions of what are we going to do
we're already supplying the the the the
the the arms so uh you know I think
we're lucky this is when I look at this
I go if this is what we got to worry
about we're okay but I you know how long
will this go on well we're lucky and
we're smart because we have an unmanned
drone up there we're not putting any of
our air guys I do wonder if it had been
manned if it wouldn't have happened at
all I don't think they would have
touched because he doesn't want an U.S
pilot absolutely I wonder Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now